[Music]
I've been a television talk show host
for almost 21 years almost 21 yes I've
been doing this guy hey your plan worked
perfectly please yes and clearly if you
watch the show regularly I've mastered
the form oh you know I've attained a
level of perfection right which cannot
be equalled right Hey in the top show
you're like well Jedi Master yeah a talk
show with him of talk show ISM which is
not even a word so I thought it was time
to begin a new chapter in my career as a
dramatic film actor now I don't have a
lot of time to launch a new career in
film cuz I'm getting a little long in
the tooth hmm I'm 87 years old this is a
bad wig so what I did and so I don't
have a lot of time so I chose the first
and only film role offered to me I'm
talking about the powerful
hyper-realistic drama Sharktopus versus
tarakudo
[Applause]
thank you now of course it's the story
of a creature that's part shark part
octopus who battles a creature that's
part pterodactyl part Barracuda it's
produced by Roger Corman producer of
classic American films like women in
cages and death race 2000 now we shot
the movie okay and I'm very proud of my
work in this film and I wanted the whole
world to know about it so here's what I
did I demanded a high-profile billboard
on LA Sunset Strip where all of
Hollywood's biggest players would see it
because everyone in town drives past
sure that's where it'll all see my
billboard and I'm in this movie and that
makes me an a-lister overnight
unfortunately I found out several hours
ago that the prime real estate on Sunset
Strip was not available so I got the
next best thing
check it out a prominent spot in the
heart of LA's historic breaks and
alignment district beautiful
that's gonna be 160 feet long it's
gorgeous yeah there's of course tons of
foot traffic in that area there he goes
yeah yeah just released from prison my
billboard has views of some of the
city's natural beauty which is very nice
everything oh yeah plus I've got a great
discount on this billboard because the
billboard has a partially obstructed
view check it out
[Music]
best of all you don't have to travel all
the way to Sundance or kin to see this
film I demanded it be made available to
every man woman and child with a tier
two cable package that's right you don't
have to buy a ticket at a snooty theater
this movie premieres on the sci-fi
channel August 2nd at 9 p.m. Eastern
Time
with an encore presentation
[Applause]
I'm gonna be a movie star he's
incredible
you know I lost my respect for you about
15 years ago but I've got it back now
[Applause]
you